is a council official turned volunteer
Soldier for whom this war has dealt a
cruel blow
dimitro was trying to rescue a fellow
soldier who trod on a mine when his
world exploded too his left leg blown
off he thought he may die
but in this clinic in kieve he is here
to meet the man who will help give him
his life back
for 43 of his 68 years Vladimir federov
has been making molds and fitting
Prosthetics but never has he crafted as
many as he has these past few months but
it's sad that you are so busy
hold on
if there was no war there would be less
suffering he tells me but now we share
their suffering we're suffering with
them
he is part of Ukraine's hidden war
effort and for dimitro his latest
patient this is his first fitting
it has been a painful sacrifice but one
he says that is worth it
for me my motherland is like my family
he says and I want to protect my family
there is not a single day not a single
minute that I regret volunteering yes it
was dangerous but I will never regret my
decision
when he is able he wants to go back to
fight and his wife Natalia supports him
Vision she says someone has to do it
that is how it should be if God needs
him to go to war
same for many of these men being helped
by this Clinic
under therapy working hard to get back
on the front line
as many already have they claim sixty
percent of amputee soldiers in Ukraine
are making it back
but the road to recovery is a long one
and dimitro is at the beginning of it
Natalia recording every tentative step
One More Story from this war of the
Suffering The Spirit and the sacrifice